[Applaus]
[Musik]
kannst du dir vorstellen das ist in
deinem land eine ganze armee gibt deren
ausschließlicher aufgabe es ist die
offizielle ideologie der
regierungspartei zu verteidigen dhs
würden im land parallel zwei
vollständige armeen existieren jede von
ihnen würde unabhängig voneinander über
ihre eigene komplette struktur mit allen
waffengattungen verfügen aber nur eine
armee hätte die aufgabe das ganze land
zu verteidigen die andere würde
ausschließlich die verteidigung der
regierung und der politische strukturen
die das land kontrollieren sicherstellen
und nein wir reden hier nicht über
nordkorea oder china wo das ganze
militär übrigens gesetzlich der
regierungspartei und nicht dem staat
verpflichtet ist wir reden auch nicht
über hitler deutschland in dem die
wehrmacht ihren alt eben auch auf den
führer leisten musste und dieser
zusätzlich noch die ss die waffen ss als
leib armee hatte nein diese durch ihren
durch totalitäre struktur die wir in
unserem heutigen video unter die lupe
nehmen wollen existiert auch in der
islamischen republik iran einem staat
dessen aufbau einer art riesige
denksportaufgabe an sich darstellt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der iranische staat sich aus zwei großen
institutionellen strukturen zusammen auf
der einen seite geht es den religiösen
apparat eine struktur die vom obersten
führer dem ayatollah geleitet wird und
den theokratischen teil des staates
bildet vergesst nicht dass wir von einer
islamischen republik sprechen in der die
religion an der spitze der macht steht
alle macht geht dort nicht vom volke aus
sondern von ein paar alten weißen
männern die behaupten sie wären die
rechtmässigen vertreter eines einzigen
gottes auf erden aus diesem grund
besteht der religiöse apparat aus einem
netzwerk von institutionen die eine
immense macht im land haben und die
direkte dem obersten führer unterstehen
und natürlich nicht vom volk gewählt
werden das zweite system besteht aus
einem präsidenten einer regierung und
eine parlament die mehr oder weniger
demokratisch von den bürgern bzw unter
tagen gewählt werden
dieses zweites system das land politisch
lässt ist jedoch in der staatshierarchie
unter dem ayatollah angesiedelt im iran
hat die religiöse dimension eben
absoluten vorrang vor der politischen
genau das gleiche gilt für die
sicherheits und streitkräfte eine der
beiden erwähnten armeen ist der anderen
auch hierarchisch überlegen und ja
diejenige die überlegen ist ist genau
jene die unter dem direkten befehl ist
er tollered steht die rede ist vom chor
der islamischen revolutionsgarden allen
besser bekannt als die iranische
revolutionsgarde ich bin mir sicher dass
viele von euch in diesem moment die
frage gestellt werden warum ein toller
khomeini die schaffung von parallelen
streikten anordnete wenn es bereits eine
armee inneren gab nun in gewisser weise
ist die antwort nichts anderes als
mangel an vertrauen
als die islamischen revolution 1979 im
iran triumphierte erbte das neue regime
der mullahs eine armee die bis zu ihrem
sieg als kaiserliche iranische armee
bekannt war und die nutzer 21 von reza
schah dem vater von mohammed reza
pahlavi der durch die revolution
abgerissen schaffen persien gegründet
worden war tatsache ist dass die dollars
eben ernsthafte zweifel an der treue und
loyalität der iranischen armee gegenüber
der islamischen revolution und in neuen
religiösen führern hatten welche nun die
kontrolle im land übernahmen um seine
macht zu festigen und einen möglichen
erneuten staatsstreich zu verhindern
euro nach rumänien die evolutionstheorie
ließen die am sturz des vorherigen
regimes beteiligt gewesen waren so
vereinigen zu organisieren und
auszurüsten so entstand die iranische
revolutionsgarde eine parallel armee die
unter anderem auch die aufgabe hatte die
nationale armee der republik in schach
zu halten falls sie einmal aus der reihe
tanzen sollte
[Musik]
man könnte sie als prätorianergarde der
ayatollahs bezeichnet eine armee deren
hauptaufgabe nichts mit der
landesverteidigung zu tun hat sondern
mit dem schutz der revolution
und passt auf denn wir reden hier nicht
über eine einfache eliteeinheit mit ein
paar tausend soldaten ganz und gar nicht
wir sprechen hier von einer gigantischen
kraft die sowohl im militärischen als
auch im politischen und wirtschaftlichen
bereich sehr mächtig und einflussreich
ist ein staat im staate mehr noch diese
macht wächst ständig und jetzt mit einer
neuen konservativen regierung weil sie
neben macht übernommen hat kommt sie
wieder so richtig in mode denn bei dem
was diese neue regierung im schilde
führt wird sie ihre ideologische
schlägertruppe mehr brauchen denn je
irans neuer verteidigungsminister
verspricht die militärische macht des
chors der islamischen revolutionsgarden
auszubauen aber wie weit reichen die
tentakel dieser parallel armee was sind
ihre fähigkeiten welchen einfluss hat
sie wirklich auf die iranische politik
und gesellschaft und vielleicht die
wichtigste frage von allen zu welcher
art von einsätzen sind sie in der lage
also aufgepasst
[Musik]
die bread oriana garde des ayatollah
wir bereits gesagt haben ist der iran
eines der wenigen länder vielleicht
sogar das einzige in dem zwei
voneinander unabhängige streitmächte
existieren auf der einen seite gibt es
die armee der islamischen republik iran
oder acht es eine traditionelle armee
bestehend aus marine luftwaffe und heer
und auf der anderen seite gibt es die
revolutionsgarde oder ca und ja die
iranische revolutionsgarde verfügt auch
über ihre eigene marine ihre eigene
luftwaffe und ihr eigenes her denn wie
ich bereits erwähnt habe antwortet sie
und zwei parallelen die ganz gewollt
vollkommen unabhängig voneinander sind
[Musik]
zwei armeen mit unterschiedlichen pcs
haben die sich nicht einmal in den
wichtigsten fragen einig sind es ist
sogar nicht ungewöhnlich dass die
gegensätzliche positionen vertreten die
seltene kritik am chor der islamischen
revolution starbuck wurzel in der
militärischen rivalität emirat die vom
regime geschürte und geförderte
rivalität zwischen der armee und dem
chor der islamischen revolutionsgarden
hat einen punkt erreicht an dem sie das
regime untergräbt die trennung geht so
weit dass die beiden armee nicht einmal
personal oder ausrüstung gemeinsam
nutzen so dass ein kampfflugzeug der
revolutionsgarde unter keinen umständen
von der heeres wird war vor eingesetzt
werden kann und andersherum tatsächlich
ist auch ihre entwicklung sehr sehr
unterschiedlich und zum nachteil der
konventionellen armee wird die
revolutionsgarde immer wichtiger und
mächtiger unter anderem weil diese art
von parallel armee einen sehr
ungewöhnlichen vorteilhaft sie ist
hochspezialisiert auf eine bestimmte art
von krieg die immer mehr an bedeutung
gewinnt und über die wir hier auch
visuell politik bereits gesprochen haben
die asymmetrische kriegsführung
[Musik]
was mich das erklären asymmetrische
kriegsführung ist per definition eine
art der kriegsführung bei der zwei
seiten mit sehr unterschiedlichen
kräften gegeneinander antreten die
normalerweise nie in einem direkten
kampf verwickelt sind es ist jene art
von krieg in dem eine der beiden seiten
in guerilla einheiten organisiert ist
und ihre interventionen durch verdeckte
operationen kleinen blitzangriffe und
sogar anschläge und sabotage akt der
sprechen von einer strategie für die
häufig die unterstützung lokaler
organisationen wie stammesgruppen
separatisten oder bewaffneter banken
gesucht wird mit anderen worten eine art
der kriegführung die um effektiv zu sein
enorme mengen an
geheimdienstinformationen kontakten und
eine sehr gute kenntnis der umgebung
erfordert der springende punkt ist nun
dass diese art der kriegsführung in der
praxis die entwicklung hoch
spezialisierter strukturen erfordert die
sich ausschließlich auf diese mission
konzentrieren
die asymmetrische kriegsführung und
weißt du was ebenfalls der iranischen
revolutionsgarde gibt ist eine solche
struktur sie ist als kurz einheiten es
handelt sich um eine elitetruppe die
sicher viele von euch kennen und sei es
nur wegen dieser nachricht
januar 2020 usa töten kommandeur der
iranischen einheit kurz
[Musik]
wir haben auch wieso alle politik
darüber berichtet die ermordung von
custom soleimani durch die us-drohne war
ein direkter schlag gegen die wichtigste
militärische einheit dollars die gruppe
war dafür bekannt dass sie alle arten
von asymmetrischen operation durchführte
operationen wie entführungen sabotage
attentate oder auch zb die ausbildung
und ausrüstung von guerillas und
paramilitärischen kräften deren ziele
sich mit denen teheran stecken genau das
ist der fall der hisbollah und der hamas
die israel terrorisiert schließlich ist
al kurz auf der arabische name für
jerusalem die truppe trägt diesen
symbolträchtigen namen der verdeutlichen
soll worum es ihr im endziel geht und
natürlich hat sie auch an vielen anderen
orten die finger im spiel vor allem im
irak und neuerdings auch afghanistan wo
sie die taliban unterstützt aber moment
mal heißt das dass die revolutionsgarde
nur diese art von spezialoperationen im
ausland durchführen kann nein nichts
könnte weiter von der wahrheit entfernt
sein die wahrheit ist dass diese
organisation eine gigantische präsenz in
der iranischen politik hat und zwar
nicht nur in der politik sondern auch in
der wirtschaft des landes
so kontrolliert die revolutionsgarde
unter anderem direkt medien
bildungseinrichtungen und sogar gas und
ölfelder außerdem konnte die
revolutionsgarde dank der rolle die ihr
nach dem krieg mit dem irak der das 1 88
endete beim wiederaufbauen zugewiesen
wurde enge beziehungen zu mehr als 100
bauunternehmen und konstruktions firmen
knüpfen die ein kapital von rund zwölf
milliarden dollar verwalten all diese
aktivitäten und riesige stadt haushalte
direkt oder indirekt durch seine hände
fließt machen das korps zur mächtigsten
organisationen des irans ich möchte dir
eine vorstellung davon vermitteln womit
wir es hier zu tun haben würde ist auch
an wie es ein iranischer dissident
beschreibt er einst selbst zu den
mitbegründern dieser kam erzählte dass
dich fest
ich kenne keine andere organisationen
irgendeinem land wie die
revolutionsgarden sie ist so etwas wie
die kommunistische partei der kgb der
militärisch industrielle komplex und die
mafia in einem maxi kahre ab
gründungsmitglied des chors der
revolutionsgarden
denn was die truppenstärke angeht steht
die revolutionsgarde auf einer stufe mit
so bedeutenden armeen wie den
frankreichs deutschlands oder
großbritannien
von den 523.000 aktiven
militärangehörigen der islamischen
republik iran gehört 190.000 zu den
revolutionsgarden davon bilden zwischen
17.000 21.000 die als kurz brigade
bekannte elite gruppe und das ist noch
nicht das ende der fahnenstange darüber
hinaus kontrolliert die revolutionsgarde
auch ihre eigene paramilitärische gruppe
die bastille keine religiösen milieus
die etwa 600.000 mitglieder zählt welche
die revolutionsgarde häufig einsetzt um
die zivilgesellschaft zu kontrollieren
zum beispiel und demonstrationen oder
proteste zu unterdrücken
tatsächlich kann das iranische regime
mit hilfe der bastille truppen alle
möglichen grausamkeiten begehen wie zb
menschen willkürlich verprügeln
verhaften oder foltern ohne dass sich
die offiziellen sicherheitskräfte die
hände schmutzig machen müssen dessen
zeugen konnten wir zum beispiel 2009 10
werden während der massiven proteste
gegen das iranische regime
irans staatschef forderte
niederschlagung der unruhen an tut alles
um sie zu beenden kam einer der den iran
seit drei jahrzehnten regiert wandte
sich an seine elitetruppen um die
jüngsten unruhen niederzuschlagen
die revolutionsgarden und die mit ihnen
verbundenen religiöse bassidsch-miliz
während er weniger als zwei wochen
dauernden unruhen die am 15 november
begangen wurden etwa 1500 menschen
getötet unter den auffangen die reuters
von drei beamten des iranischen
staatsministerium genannt wurden waren
mindestens 17 jugendliche und etwa 400
frauen sowie einige mitglieder der
sicherheitskräfte und der polizei
und gibt es aber noch eine frage die wir
beantworten müssen wie funktioniert es
in einem statt zwei parallel armeen zu
haben wie muss das ganze system
aufgestellt sein damit so etwas
langfristig funktioniert also schauen
das ist doch mal genauer an
eine wachsende kraft
[Musik]
die geschichte der iranischen
revolutionsgarde ist gelinde gesagt
kurios und zwar deshalb weil ihr
aufstieg zur macht mit einem
militärischen fiasko verbunden war
während des ersten golfkriegs in den der
iran der atlas zwischen 1980 1988 gegen
den irak von saddam hussein kämpfte
spielte die revolutionsgarde eine
entscheidende rolle als saddam husseins
september 1980 in den iran
einmarschierte war die irakische armee
eine der modernsten berufsarmeen der
welt die revolutionsgarde hingegen war
zu dieser zeit eine bunt
zusammengewürfelte miliz aus miserabel
ausgebildeten und schlecht bewaffneten
rekruten vergiss nicht dass die
islamische revolution im iran gerade mal
ein jahr zurücklag und der befehl des
ayatollahs die vielen bunten milizen zur
revolutionsgarde zu vereinen zu
professionalisieren und auszurüsten doch
nicht in kraft getreten war erschwerend
kam hinzu dass sich auch die nationale
armee in einer sehr prekären lage befand
was vor allem auf internes säuberungen
und die flucht vieler offiziere nach dem
triumph der islamischen revolution
zurückzuführen war das ergebnis war eine
katastrophe vielleicht nicht das aller
schlimmste szenario aber schon ein
ziemlich schrecklich ist viel
schrecklicher als uns das je vorstellen
könnten die irakische invasion hat er
ohne vorstellbare menschliche verluste
zur folge hunderttausende iranischer
soldaten wurden als kanonenfutter da
hingemetzelt und auch mehr als 100.000
zivilisten starben dieses brutalen
konflikt
der punkt war jedoch dass niemand mehr
blut vergossen und mehr märkte auf dem
schlachtfeld geopfert hatte heißt die
revolutionsgarde und die baskisch
millies damit konnte das regime von
ajatollah khomeini nun sagen dass es
über eine äußerst loyale trupps verfügt
ja und loyalität loyalität ist genau das
was du brauchst wenn du eine revolution
und ein tyrannisches regime
konsolidieren willst die religiösen
autoritäten sagen damals glasklar dass
sie ihre eigene prätorianergarde braucht
eine gut ausgebildete vollkommen autark
truppe die auf alle arten von verdeckten
operationen spezialisiert ist und den
ganzen staat durchzudringen in der lage
ist so etwas wie die eiserne faust des
glaubens gesagt getan
die ayatollahs starteten diese gruppen
dazu mit mehr macht mehr mitteln und
mehr schlagkraft aus während also die
konventionelle armee weiterhin die
nationalen grenzen schützt haben die
ayatollahs ihre eigene schock truppe
entwickelt eine kraft die es ihnen
ermöglicht ihren einfluss über die
landesgrenzen hinaus auszudehnen die
geheim diese zu kontrollieren die
unterwanderung des landes durch
ausländische mächte zu bekämpfen und
notfalls auch das theokratische regime
zu verteidigen koste es was es wolle
denn das letzte wort hat am ende immer
derjenige der eine solche ultimative
macht besitzt und es ist klar dass du in
dein vorgesetzter r dollar ist in einer
besseren position bist als diejenigen
die einen präsidenten unterstellt sind
welcher religiösen macht untergeordnet
ist das ergebnis ist dass die
revolutionsgarde in all den jahren die
streitkräfte der islamischen republik
nach und nach als das wahre symbol und
die referenz für nationale sicherheit
verdrängt hat
[Musik]
so ist es beispielsweise die
revolutionsgarde und nicht die armee
welche über die meisten der tausenden
von kurz und mittelstreckenraketen
verfügt die das herz israels angreifen
könnten und heute zur wichtigsten
abschreckungs macht des landes geworden
sind das gleiche gilt für die neuen
panzer panzerfahrzeuge und sogar
jagdbomber es kommt immer häufiger vor
dass dieses politische militärische
gremium als erstes die besten ressourcen
zugeteilt bekommt ihr stil und er modus
operandi bleiben jedoch genau dieselben
[Musik]
das südkoreanische flagge durch iran
beschlagnahmt so fordert freilassen so
diese operation sei kein geringerer als
die iranischen revolutionsgarden
verantwortlich sie kaperten einen unter
südkoreanischer flagge fahrenden tanker
der gerade den persischen golf unterwegs
war und hielten die besatzung fest
inmitten der spannungen zwischen teheran
und so legen iranischer gelder die auf
grund der us-sanktionen in
südkoreanischen banken eingefroren
wurden
übrigens willst du wissen wie diese
geschichte ausging nun nachdem das
schiff zwischen januar und april 2021
festgehalten wurde wurde es schließlich
vom iran freigelassen aber nicht umsonst
hieran lässt südkoreanische schiff und
kapitän frei nach versprechen mit
eingefrorenen geldern zu helfen der iran
hat am freitag ein südkoreanisches
schiff und seinen kapitän freigelassen
nachdem südkorea versprochen hatte sich
um die freigabe iranischer gelder zu
bemühen die aufgrund von us-sanktionen
in südkoreanischen banken eingefroren
worden waren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tja wie du sie ist gehört zum
aufgabenbereich der privaten also auch
piraterie geiselnahme und erpressung das
jedenfalls ist die geschichte der
iranischen revolutionsgarde dem start in
einem startet mit zwei armeen sicher
gebe es noch viel mehr zu erzählen zum
beispiel über den gewaltigen
geschäftlichen arm des chors welcher die
wirtschaft ist 83 millionen landes
dominiert aber darüber machen wir lieber
ein eigenes video vergisst also bitte
nicht das auto und das glöckchen und
keines mehr zu verpassen und wenn du das
getan hast du uns bitte noch einen
kleinen gefallen und schreibt uns was du
über die revolutionsgarde und den iran
text glaubst du dass die wachsende
bedeutung der iranischen
revolutionsgarde zu ernsthaften
reibereien mit den streitkräften der
islamischen republik führen könnte was
hältst du von diesem modell ein land
zwei armeen weißt du es könnte bei einer
demokratisierung des landes weiter
bestehen die immer sind auf all eure
meinung zu diesem thema hochgradig
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat was ja gibt es mit
einem like weil es mit euren falcon und
vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen und
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
was gut und bis bald
[Musik]